oh yeah you came like kalila yeah was
raised in a different country yeah
how old are you I was 12 so you spent a
good man yeah I was a person already you
know yeah and it was a weird transition
I never talked about it on stage I got
joke about it a little but it was it was
traumatic what happens to 12 years you
lived in Brazil 12 years I lived in
Brazil well my real in Sao Paulo city
like in the building all the time dreamt
about a pool you know like I would see
American movies and be like well you
know yeah the American dream and then we
came to Virginia and it was snowing we
had never seen snow before we were like
what the [ __ ] is this
yeah and all the kids in the
neighborhood donated clothes to us
because we didn't have like snow clothes
I just had this like Jets jacket I
remember very vividly
we had like shower caps on our feet and
this neighbor girl came over and offered
his hot cocoa and cocoa means poop and
Portuguese yeah yeah and we had to go
apologize and blah blah I'm like we
always kind of had a rivalry with that
girl ever since that I was almost 1500
similar story except I came to yeah from
the Philippines same thing when I
watched movie so I always thought wow
America's a great indie go I lived in
the [ __ ] pits of LA and the ghetto my
I thought I was living high class yeah I
thought I wrote home like we live next
to a Kentucky Fried Chicken
[Laughter]
they don't serve it with rice they serve
it with Bologna and it was first week of
November and we I had three sweaters on
it's an LA because I was so [ __ ] cold
and I we live in a cockroach infested
one-bedroom apartment but I thought to
myself wow this is it guys we made it we
did make it though I mean it's I think
about this all the time like they they
sat my mom sacrificed her literal life
yeah in a cool place where she knew
everybody mm-hmm to like a place where
you know people treated her like [ __ ]
because she had seen it and my mom would
work a 12-hour shift to get paid $20
under the table for the whole day as a
caretaker and they they date
oh [ __ ] yeah and she would take three
buses to get there and it was but in her
mind it was so grand and big and
something she could be proud of
and I never ins I mean I didn't have a
car until I was 23 even cuz I just had a
bus pass my whole life but I never
thought to myself wow I'm I'm not doing
well I always felt thankful yeah like
you know what this is okay like reliving
okay I'm a different country yeah my
sister I understand how we had a
pull-out couch from my sister and I my
parents left on the floor but I still
thought this is grand yeah
it doesn't occur to you you can't but
then you come from bought a Highland
[ __ ] firstworldproblems it really
wears on me I know our family always
like kind of slept in the same rooms in
hotel room we just didn't understand
that people didn't do that right we just
didn't get it yeah it was cuz and also
we're so physical too that's another
weird thing that was like people are
like why are you hugging me worried yeah
etching me we hold hands with your
family you're a bad sister everybody I
kiss my mom in the mouth yeah it's it's
it's you know it's not okay very sexy
very urban dictionary but that's so
you're saying that that is from a
different country yeah my mom will come
into the bathroom and pee while my
sister and I are both showering yeah
you're good with that yeah I mean my dad
wouldn't come in there and take a [ __ ]
while we're like showering yeah yeah
yeah because my dad was showering and my
brother and I would walk in there he
would get out of the shower and then
whip us with a towel naked well your
brotherís us together so you know what I
would would be - what do you mean sauced
I mean I'm sauce like suspicious like I
would I would probably the guys are
tricky tricky tricky pear yeah it's too
quiet
well what Kat are you fingering
[Laughter]
whoa yeah every accurate but wha-what
yeah
well that's interesting that you guys
had similar kind of name Anna and she's
from Romania and very very similar
stories yeah I I don't want to say we're
better but I think that there is a
little bit of an element of having lived
a little bit more a little bit faster
when you grow up in a country that's not
particularly rich oh yeah and I think
you see a lot of things that you don't
ever and I think that's a luxury to see
those things very at a very young age
well also they say your brain is capable
more things when you're when you speak
more languages it opens like parts of
your brain that neurologically people
that speak one language really will
never hear you speak Portuguese I do
flowly
really like say something weird thing to
about social like socially kids in other
countries or like more adult more
grown-up and like devot because they
have to grow up fast and then you come
here and kids are like picking their
nose and [ __ ] and eating it in fourth
grade you're like what is this idea I
was talking about maybe having sex last
week
[Music]